laval et la vallée corruption collusion
geneviève jeanson offshore val d'or
shafia revenu canada usines à chiots
commission charbonneau
on célèbre ce soir la 200e émission d'
enquête bonne fête au caire
de plus
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs et
bienvenue à cette émission toute
spéciale qui marque que la 200e édition
d' enquête et on en est très heureux
le retour officiel d'isabel richer
bonsoir isabelle jean marie monde
si vous saviez comment moi je suis
heureuse d'être ici et cette 200e
émission
eh ben c'est l'occasion rêvée de revenir
sur les reportages qui vous ont marqué
au fil des neuf dernières années plus de
350 enquêtes qui vous ont révélé des
réalités des reportages qui vous ont
parfois émue mais souvent indignée et ce
soir on vous propose d'entrer dans les
coulisses de la préparation de ses
reportages
l'idée de départ vient souvent de vous
au fil des ans vous nous avez envoyé
toutes sortes d'informations sous toutes
sortes de formes que ce soit des
affaires des courriels les bonnes
vieilles enveloppes brunes et plus
récemment vous moderniser en soit de
plus en plus de clés usb et même parfois
isabelle des disques durs externes
complet rempli de fichiers merci on aime
beaucoup ça oui parce que l' enquête
journalistique c'est d'abord et avant
tout une affaire de preuves et le début
d'un reportage ça tire souvent à une
information infiniment petit comme il y
a trois ans lorsque notre collègue
sylvie fournier au regard des chaque
fraction de seconde d'une bande vidéo
des émeutes de victoriaville
c'était dans le cadre du printemps
érables et ont découvert une toute autre
réalité que la version officielle de la
police
s'il y a un moment à victoriaville où la
police peut se défendre d'avoir recours
à la force c'est celui ci quand un
policier sans protection est agressé
pendant qu'il tente une arrestation
c'est là que la majorité des balles de
plastique sont tirés je pense que c'est
une des images que les gens ont retenu
des manifestations étudiantes alors
c'est victoriaville la fin du printemps
érable et il ya ce policier par terre
qui est agressé par les manifestants
c'est tellement fort comme image on est
captivé par ça et ça m'a pris beaucoup
de temps de rencontres qui se passe est
autre chose dans cette image là ça
faisait déjà un certain temps qu'on
examinait le visuel parce qu'on avait
des doutes sur la version policière et
un moment donné on s'est rendu compte
que dans cette image là c'était le
moment précis où un des manifestants est
grièvement blessé par un tir de
projectile
elles étaient environ 2 ou 300 mètres
des policiers lorsque ça s'est produit
et je vous rappelle que la portée
maximale d'un projectile d'impact
utilisait la sûreté du québec c'est 100
m trois conférences de presse en huit
jours
et à chaque fois la sûreté du québec
martèle qu'il est impossible que les
policiers aient pu causer c'est bien sûr
là ce qui nous a aidé c'est que c'est le
congrès du parti libéral du québec et
c'est en plein coeur d'une crise sociale
sans précédent alors radio canada quand
même déployer des ressources sur le
terrain
alors on hérite d'une tonne d'image et
le défi l'heure si les visionner il ya
eu des heures de visionnement sonia
démarrer entre autres la réalisatrice
qui le passé des soirées entières mais
c'est comme assembler les morceaux d'un
quart à stains est un moment donné
l'image apparaît et on s'est rendu
compte qu'on était capable de
reconstituer la chronologie des
événements
pratiquement à la seconde près 18h55 46
secondes
alexandre allard se repère dans la foule
son avance moins on ne tourne comme ceux
issus donc c'est combien tu as à peu
près 20 aux jeunes seront qu'à 30
secondes et 12 secondes plus tard noté
le policier qui s'avance au fond il tire
un léger nuage entoure le projectile
au même moment sur ces images d'un
témoin prise en sens inverse
on aperçoit aussi un policier qui vise
les manifestants tout de suite après
alexandre allard et au sol le crâne
fracassé
ce qui a été important pour moi c'est
que quand les autorités nous donne la
version officielle de l'événement
peut-être que des fois il nous
sous-estiment un peu mais il faut pas
penser qu'on voit simplement relayé
l'information parce qu'elle vient d'une
source officielle
sans la vérifier et si des erreurs aussi
des émissions mais il ya des bonnes
chances contre en rendre compte
et je pense que ma plus grande fierté
c'est ça c'est d'avoir rectifié les
faits sur ce qui a pu se produire et
victoriaville 7,6 lui fournit à trouver
une aiguille dans une botte de foin
mais pour notre collègue frédéric zajac
c'était le problème inverse le problème
de l' infiniment grand trouver une bonne
histoire dans une fuite de documents 160
fois plus importante que wikileaks
je suis ce journaliste dans 15 qui n'est
pas au québec mon poste de travail est à
vancouver mais en fait c'est plus une
fenêtre sur le monde que j'ai à partir
de là où je me trouve parce que j'ai
joint depuis 2012
un regroupement qui s'appelle le
consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation
c'est un groupe qui est basé à
washington petit organisme sans but
lucratif mais qui peut compter qui
réunit en fait des près de 200
journalistes à travers la planète des
journalistes en quête qui font
exactement le même métier le même genre
de travail que nous et regrouper tous
ses journalistes là pour pouvoir
s'attaquer à des sujets d'ordre mondial
qu'on parle d'environnement de finances
le monde est interrelié puis on est en
train de voir une nouvelle façon de
faire du journalisme d'enquêté en groupe
mais depuis 2013 ce consortium là qui
s'appelle la ici à alger a fait
plusieurs grandes enquêtes sur les
paradis fiscaux ces enquêtes là on fait
les manchettes à travers le monde entier
et on fait même réagir de très hauts
dirigeants parce que les paradis fiscaux
doivent être éradiquées le plus récent
projet de la csg c'est celui sur les
ultra riches clients de la banque privée
hsbc en suisse et ces données là ont
permis à travers une fuite de découvrir
qu'il y avait énormément fraude
d'évasion fiscale qui se produisait à
l'échelle de la planète parmi ses
clients ils ce sont des journalistes du
journal le monde en france qui avait
d'abord obtenu cette fuite là et qui ont
décidé de la partager avec tous ces
journalistes lui à travers le monde
on peut pas travailler sur canada sur
les usa sur l'argentine sur la russie
devenir efficace comme ça dans votre
coin
l'intérêt c'est de comprendre le système
de le démonter pour le démonter on est
meilleur à plusieurs que tout seul alors
pour lancer projet on s'est retrouvé
plusieurs douzaines de gens allaient son
s'est réuni à paris dans les locaux du
journal le monde
et ç'a permis de rencontrer des gens
d'un peu partout dans les grands médias
comme le guardian la bbc et même la
vénérable institution de cbs sixty
manette c'est hélas c'est un casse tête
il ya des grands avantages à travailler
en groupe comme ça on peut se partager
du visuel de tournage partager notre
recherche
mais il faut aussi faire normand de
compromis et coordonner tout ça qu'on
allait la date de diffusion qui peut des
fois tout un casse-tête est aussi
s'assurer que tout ça reste secret
jusqu'à la fin par la force de frappe
d'une équipe comme celle-là est énorme
il est très difficile d'y visiter un
sujet qu'un c'est traiter en profondeur
à travers toute la planète et on
continue à préparer d'autres reportages
en collaboration avec ce groupe de
reporters à travers le monde
sylvie fournier a remporté le prix
judith jasmin pour le reportage sur
victoriaville et frédéric zajac et le
récipiendaire d'un prix match ne l'un
des prix de journalisme les plus
prestigieux au canada et parcs à se
monter voici quelques-uns des prix
remportés par l'émission enquête
après la pause quelques unes de nos
techniques denquête y compris
l'infiltration en fait on se teste ses
100 euros
non
on vous révèle maintenant quelques
petits secrets de ces techniques
denquête qu'on a utilisées au fil des
ans pour obtenir certaines informations
parce qu'une fois identifié comme
journaliste bien des portes se referment
à double tour c'est pour cette notre
collègue luc chartrand s'est déguisé
pour une enquête sur les produits
naturels mais aussi pour aller à la
chasse en gaspésie on a plusieurs fois
choisi de modifier mon apparence pour
des enquêtes ont fait ça généralement
parce que ça peut nous donner accès à
des informations qu'on pourrait pas
obtenir autrement et bien sûr les normes
sont très strictes à radio-canada et on
pourrait pas diffuser des images
recueillies comme ça si elle ne
démontrait pas un comportement illégal
ou anti sociale
donc c'est strict ces normes note donc
on doit les appliquer je la première
fois je me suis transformée au cours
d'un reportage sur wal mart lashayna
chaîne de grands magasins où j'aurai
décidé de me faire embaucher comme
employé une manutentionnaire donc ça va
être un long travail d'infiltration je
mettais modifié passablement
physiquement on n'avait pas réussi à
démontrer des comportements qui
répondait aux critères que j'ai dénoncé
donc on n'avait pas diffuser ces images
là mais quand même ma femme avait
immortalisé la scène sur mon mac parties
à travailler ce qui avait fait rire
beaucoup de monde autour de moi
j'avais repris ce genre d'expérience au
cours d'une enquête sur les médecines
douces
oui là je mettais transformer en
propriétaire d'une boutique de produits
de santé naturels ce qui nous permettait
d'avoir accès aux fournisseurs de ces
produits et qui nous avait permis de
démontrer la fabrication extrêmement
douteuse de certains de ses produits et
même la présence de produits
complètement illégaux sur les tablettes
des grandes chaînes de pharmacies ce qui
avait permis le retrait de ces produits
dernièrement dans notre enquête sur
l'intimidation à la chasse à l'orignal
le caméraman pierre mainville
le réalisateur dany cros à témoin mais
nous étions transformer ou fait passer
pour un groupe de chasseurs d'orignal
qui allions chasse en gaspésie au cours
de cette opération je vais te fait
pousser une barbe mais tout au long du
reportage lorsque nous confrontions des
gens qui nous intime il est j'étais
toujours filmés de dos alors des gens ne
peut pas voir à quoi je ressemblais
vraiment m'y étais pas question que je
puisse être reconnu par les gens sur le
terrain son camion bloque l'accès au
territoire et nous lui demandons le
passage la place alors en première ce
soir avec une certaine humilité je vous
permet de voir à quoi je ressemblais de
face voici d'ailleurs les fausses dents
utilisé par luc chartrand lors de son
reportage sur la chasse
on va les garder ça pourrait peut-être
servir explorer les réseaux sociaux et
voyez ce que notre collègue chantal
lavigne réussi à faire pour mettre en
lumière le phénomène des djihadistes au
canada pour notre enquête sur les
djihadistes en 2014 on utiliser les
médias sociaux
ou plutôt on a ratissé les médias
sociaux parce que c'est là que ça se
passe
et surtout ça se passait à ce moment-là
alors à la fin du printemps un chercheur
nous montre des photos des vidéos
publiée sur le compte facebook de
jihadistes en syrie qui se dit de
montréal
des images saisissantes où il montre son
visage on le voit en action et il se
présente sous le pseudonyme d'elles
s'est mis alors à partir de ce moment là
notre objectif c'est d'essayer à partir
depuis les indices laissés sur ce compte
facebook de découvrir qui ce jeune homme
d' essayer de retracer son histoire pour
mieux comprendre ce phénomène du
djihadiste qui qui prenait de l'ampleur
et qui était moins connu qu'aujourd'hui
l'huile appartenait à la première
génération de combattants étrangers qui
étaient partis avant l'émergence de
l'état islamique sur le devant de la
scène
il s'était donc joint au groupe elle
nous sera au front à yousra qui est
l'alliée officiel d'al qaïda en syrie
mais on ne sait pas trop quel est son
rôle précis au sein du front elle nous
sera au début ça me laisse entendre que
sa vie quotidienne est plutôt agréable
tout est gratuit ici on bouge pour qu'on
veut l'engagement de samy dans le djihad
s'affermit en janvier 2014
il met en ligne une vidéo où on le voit
brûler son passeport canadien avant de
le prendre pour cible
on a appris par la suite qu'elle sami a
été une figure influente pour plusieurs
autres québécois radicaliser entre
autres pour ce jeune reconnu coupable
avant les fêtes d'avoir tenté de quitter
le pays dans le but de commettre un acte
terroriste à l'étranger
ils ont échangé selon la police ses
proches mon pote de nouvelles récentes
de lui il est toujours actif sur twitter
il se présente maintenant comme
combattant indépendant et toujours sur
twitter nous avons communiqué avec lui
récemment et ce qu'il nous dit c'est que
effectivement il est toujours aussi
critique du groupe armé état islamique
mais qu'il a effectivement quitté le
groupe annoncera auquel il était affilié
qui pas parce qu'il n'appuie plus ce
groupe mais pour des questions
salariales dutil salaires étaient
suffisants pour vivre convenablement
par ailleurs il ne souhaite toujours pas
revenir au canada
il affirme que c'est un pays islamophobe
et il ne recommande pas aux réfugiés
musulmans de venir s'y installer
et il affirme aussi qu'il est toujours
prêt à mourir pour sa religion
facebook twitter sont toujours utilisés
pour la propagande mais si vous voulez
pour les informations plus stratégique
plus sensibles personnel
les jihadistes se tournent de plus en
plus vers des applications de messagerie
en crypté comme télégramme
what's up kicks et je crois qu'il aurait
été difficile de faire ce même reportage
aujourd'hui mais nous allons continuer à
suivre le dossier l' arme secrète
denquête c'est notre équipe de recherche
chantal cauchy détentrice d'un doctorat
en caméra cachée benoit michaud qui
combat présentement une dépendance aux
bases de données en général et aux
fichiers excel en particulier et daniel
tremblay qui cultivent les sources de
haut niveau et la discrétion
après la pause les défis d'enquêté à
l'étranger
bonne fête en choeur
pardo au cours des neuf dernières années
nous étions pour mener des enquêtes
partout à travers le monde et isabelle
au printemps dernier vous êtes allé en
italie et vous avez découvert que ce qui
est parfois très clair avant de partir
ne l'est plus du tout une fois rendu sur
place
en effet après des mois de négociations
on avait obtenu la permission
d'interviewer un délateur en prison qui
avait retourné sa veste contre la mafia
on va d'ailleurs vous présenter ça au
cours des prochaines semaines mais avant
de s'envoler pour l'italie
on s'est assuré d'avoir une lettre
d'entente avec les autorités mais quand
on est arrivé là bas
pas question d'entrer en prison avec une
caméra c'est quoi le problème
eh ben on s'appelle radio canada alors
pour eux forcément on ne travaillait pas
avec une caméra bon est ce que vous leur
avez expliqué qu on était ici radio
canada télé oui j'ai fait ça mais
c'était pas un argument très convaincant
cependant l'entente qu'on avait avec eux
démontrait bien qu'on avait la
permission pour trois personnes
isabel richer journaliste emmanuel
marchand réalisateur et jean-pierre
gants d'un caméraman et ceux qui ne ment
pas comment ça s'est terminé et ben ça
s'est conclu dans le bureau du directeur
de la prison autour d'un espresso et ont
obtenu la permission et on a pu tourner
des très belles images une excellente
entrevue
bon voilà très hâte de voir cette
enquête italienne isabelle parmi les
reportages à l'étranger qui vous ont le
plus marqué l'enquète de johan fauché
sur la mort tragique des soeurs noémie
et audrey bélanger en thaïlande
elle va vous en parlait dans un moment
mais d'abord anne panassac vous
raconteront difficile voyage en libye
pour déterrer les secrets de snc lavalin
un des pays où ça a été difficile de
filmer c'est la libye la patrie de l'ex
dictateur kadhafi parce que c'est un
pays qui est sans réel gouvernement il
ya des milices armées partout qui
surveille les quartiers de la métropole
qui surveille les villages avec des
guérites qui surveillent l'entrée la
sortie s'était dit ce libre dames en
pour nout étrangers de passer inaperçu
mais on voulait absolument aller en
libye pour filmer les chantiers de
construction de snc lavalin
vous rappelez avant la chute du régime
snc lavalin avaient des contrats juteux
avec la libye et nous avions déjà des
informations de l'enquète suisses qui
soupçonnaient qui avait des millions $
qui a été versé un pot de vin pour
obtenir justement ces contrats là
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
snc lavalin au canada est accusée au
criminel à cause de ces actes en libye
et c'est rare qu'est une entreprise
c'est à dire vraiment une entité qui
soit qu'on accusés et non pas seulement
les ex employés
et nous voulions aller à la prison ou
snc lavalin a vu un contrat de
construction
et quand on est arrivé là c'est comme si
le chantier venait juste d'être évacué à
la hâte la prison était construite en
partenariat avec une brigade de l'armée
libyenne dirigée par saadi kadhafi le
troisième fils de l'ex dictateur
plus qu'une simple association c'était
une filiale de snc lavalin dont le logo
est un mélange du bleu de la firme et du
vert du régime de kadhafi depuis la
révolution
le chantier est arrêté et des milices
montent la garde pour éviter le pillage
leur chef n'a aucun doute que cette
prison aurait servi à torturer comme les
autres prisons de kadhafi et pendant
qu'on filmait confié on ne trouvait des
casques le casque de du fils kadhafi
mais aussi le casque de construction de
idrissa gorak qui travaillait pour snc
lavalin et monsieur zagorac et le marié
de l'ambassadrice canadienne en libye à
cette époque et pour moi ça démontrait
le lien qui avait entre snc lavalin le
canada et la libye le régime kadhafi
j'étais à s'exciter de marsan puis ans
le prometteur prêté après moindre ville
prendre le café vient pour les cafés les
munitions ont préparé le café d'un train
de refroidir et c'est une très grande un
politicien qui aurait pu nous emmener
d'amendé conséquence pas très agréable à
l'émission enquête on a tout de suite
été très touché par la mort de audrey et
noémie bélanger du deux soeurs qui sont
mortes en thaïlande et on a voulu savoir
ce qui s'était passé
on est lors de notre séjour
toutes les pistes nous mener vers une
boisson une boisson toxique et audi
qu'ils auraient consommé et c'était la
version officielle que le gouvernement
voulait nous donner novembre mais
finalement c'était pas ça du tout
l'institut de norvège contact des
experts à travers le monde dont le
laboratoire de sciences judiciaires et
de médecine légale de montréal chargé de
faire une deuxième autopsie de noémie et
audrey bélanger
selon les analyses du laboratoire de
montréal le phosphure d'aluminium
pourrait être en cause dans son rapport
l'institut de santé publique de norvège
conclu que les quatre jeunes filles
mortes sur l'aide de pipi julie boy reim
''j'ai saintonge noémie et audrey
bélanger avait tout les mêmes symptômes
ils ont fort probablement été intoxiqué
par un pesticide et ce pesticide serait
le phosphure d'aluminium si on utilise
ce produit dans les hauteurs
l'utilisation de ce mot doit entraîner
la mort presque assuré de tout ce qui
vit quand on a su que les deux filles
avaient probable fort probablement été
intoxiqués au futur de l'ue minium et
que ce produit est interdit
autant en thaïlande qu'au canada dans
les hôtels dans les maisons on a voulu
savoir qui vend ce produit là et on est
décidé de retourner en thaïlande cette
fois avec une caméra cachée et on
voulait aller dans les compagnies
d'extermination pour savoir qui vendent
et ça on a embauché une fixeur bon
moment pour nous aider avec la langue
mais aussi quelqu'un qui était à l'aise
avec la caméra et qui connaissait un peu
journalistes en caisse on est allé dans
plusieurs compagnies et à un certain
moment donné
après on l'avait interviewé un vendeur
et la journaliste reçoit un appel de sa
part
et là elle est devenu blême est là je
sais pas ce qu'il lui a dit il a sans
doute menacé en tout cas certainement il
a intimidé
parce qu'à la fin de cet appel là elle
nous dit à nous annoncer
c'est fini j'arrête ici c'est trop
dangereux pour moi je peux pas aller
plus loin et là on s'est rendu compte
comme on est chanceux de faire du jaune
est en quête au canada parce que
beaucoup de pays dont la thaïlande où
c'est beaucoup plus difficile et
finalement on a réussi à trouver la
compagnie qui vendait ce produit là et
qui en vante l emirates
jointe faucher nous revient cette saison
avec un reportage percutant tournée en
france et en belgique sur les attaques
de paris après la pause
entrevue avec un témoin mystère il a
animé l'émission enquête pendant huit
ans je ne vous en dis pas plus
on poursuit cette émission spéciale 200e
d' enquête et on parle maintenant d'un
sujet épineux les sources
oui parce que réussir à faire parler
quelqu'un qui détient des informations
sensibles
c'est tout un défi très difficile et qui
de mieux que notre prédécesseur à la
barbe enquête pour en parler alain
gravel
bonsoir alors ce qui a vraiment mis en
quête sur la carte ce sont les aveux que
geneviève jeanson vous office est au
tout début de l'émission
c'est vraiment un bon exemple du travail
passe hier nos journalistes pour gagner
la confiance de quelqu'un il pour gagner
la confiance de quelqu'un il faut passer
du temps alors moi je voulais quand
j'étais à phoenix dure un jour des fois
avec un vélo donc avec geneviève jeanson
et un soir donc tranquillement à je
réussissais à établir un certain lien de
confiance en soi
on était un bar à 6 et elle me donne un
coup de coude comme ça en disant tic m'a
déjà battu
alors là je dis est là elle perdait de
son entraîneur donc et par la suite
évidemment la question de dopage était
plus difficile à démontrer
on ne finit par resserrer l'étau un tel
point qu'il a fini par craquer
un mois plus tard nous retournons pour
la quatrième fois phoenix à la fin
juillet j'ai sauvé sa peau bien sauf que
j'étais jeune j'avais paul et moi
j'avais aucun outil j'avais pas les
moyens de m'en sortir je savais pas
comment je voulais pas décevoir personne
je savais pas quoi faire bon ça ce qu'on
vient de voir c'est quelqu'un qui
accepte de faire des révélations chocs à
la caméra non on peut dire alain c'est
plutôt l'exception
si ce que plus d'ici donc convaincre des
gens de venir à la caméra ça prend des
fois du temps et même quand les gens
nous disent oui par exemple le vendredi
nous disent à mes joueurs parlent à ma
femme ou encore à mon avocat pire chose
qui puisse arriver
donc il faut parfois se résoudre à faire
des entrevues avec des gens qu'on
connaît mais dont on doit taire
l'identité parce qu'ils ont peur des
représailles soit leur travail soit
carrément des représailles physiques
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle des sources
confidentielles et non pas à donner
mieux nuance entre les deux donc des
gens qu'on connaît l'importance qu'on
appelle des choses de qualité on ne
valide et donc qui ces personnes là
était et des gens aussi qui nous donne
l'information corroborée par d'autres
sources
et si ce qui fait lever la chose en
journalisme et ses sources
confidentielles ont été particulièrement
importantes dans les enquêtes sur la
construction sur le financement illégal
des partis politiques en effet plusieurs
reportages sur cette question là donc à
laval sur l'administration de gilles
vaillancourt et le nos journalistes qui
a travaillé dans ce dossier là c'est
gino harel il revient sur son reportage
à laval ou si on a eu nos sources
d'ailleurs une de ces sources cela nous
a aidés dans un dossier qu'on a préparé
sur des prête noms dans le financement
politique du parti du maire gilles
vaillancourt le pro des lavallois cette
source là d'ailleurs s'était confié dans
un reportage qu'on a préparé en décembre
nos recherches sur le pro des lavallois
nous ont permis de découvrir des
pratiques encore plus troublante d'
usage de prête-nom au sein même du parti
il nous donnait l'argent puis on leur
donnait un chèque pour le montant
d'argent qui te donner c'était qui sans
ça c'était monsieur bertrand cet homme
qui a accepté de nous parler à condition
qu'on protège son identité est un ancien
militant du pro il dit avoir déjà servi
de prête-noms et avoir recruté lui même
des gens pour faire des chèques à partir
d'argent comptant c'était cinq mille
5000 à chaque fois cinq mille 5000 $ à
chaque fois on dirait que tu faire des
chèques au nom du père ou des lavallois
équipe vaillancourt puis de rapporter
l'échec quand on pouvait le monsieur
bertrand dont on parlait dans l'extrait
convient entente c'est jean bertrand qui
était à l'époque le représentant
officiel du parti pro des lavallois le
parti du maire gilles vaillancourt donc
après avoir entendu son on voulait
savoir si cette pratique de prête-noms
était répandue auprès des donateurs du
pro des lavallois et des donateurs ya eu
des centaines au fil des ans vous dire
qu'à l'époque on était déjà sur le
terrain à laval pour enquêter sur les
dons politiques mais aussi sur les
pratiques dans l'industrie la
construction souvent munis de caméras
cachées une micro caché pour une raison
bien simple c'est que le genre de propos
qu'on cherchait à obtenir qu'on voulait
capter c'était des choses qui seraient
peut-être difficilement dit en entrevue
officielle
finalement il ya une ancienne
conseillère municipale qui nous a
accepté de nous parler de ce système des
prête-noms les autres ont soigné ont
refusé de nous parler nous appelle jean
bertrand lui lé paquet l'automne 2012
avait refusé nous accorder une entrevue
mais au printemps 2013 il a été appelé
comme témoin devant la commission
charbonneau et à ce moment là il a
déclaré que la vaste majorité des
conseillers du pro des lavallois de 1995
à 2012 avait effectivement participé à
ce stratagème de prête-noms d'ailleurs
cinq d'entre eux sont aussi venus
confirmer qu'il y avait participé
d'ailleurs pour protéger l'identité
réelle de nos sources
ici arrive très souvent qu'on parle
encore doux entre nous au bureau est
contre ou des surnoms par exemple dieu
la reine la tuque les niveaux le
chasseur il y avait les boulettes qui
sortent de nom de ville ou en panne
d'inspiration je regardais mon vélo puis
je donnais donc les marques de certains
objets comme par exemple il ya une chose
qui s'applique qu'aux riches une autre
source qui s'appelait schumann ou une
autre de vinci dont j'ai bien
l'impression que la tradition la semaine
prochaine d'ailleurs j'ai une rencontre
secrète je vais trouver un petit morceau
de mon vélo là pour bison oui voilà pour
baptiser cette source
mais revenons sur les enquêtes que vous
avez faite sur le financement illégal
des partis politiques saperait été
facile à boisbriand au départ c'était un
très bon exemple d'un filon d'une source
confidentielle à boisbriand qui déjà
permis d'aller sur le terrain des
lustres une situation qui a eu un
immense impact un effet domino début mai
2009 une rencontre secrète a eu lieu
dans un restaurant de rosemère un
important entrepreneur de la région lino
zambito de la compagnie infrabec temps
en présence de la mairesse de boisbriand
sylvie st-jean de s'entendre avec deux
conseillers de l'opposition pour
empêcher la tenue d'élections le 1er
novembre
ainsi la mairesse st jean et tous les
autres conseillers à boisbriand serait
réélu sans opposition
ce qui était renversante c'est de
découvrir que boisbriand est un terreau
fertile non seulement pour ses scandales
au niveau municipal mais aussi
provincial un tel point que vous vous
avez repris le flambeau à boisbriand
mais à un niveau provincial parle de
boisbriand effectivement et c'est là
marie montrent que vous avez fait
découvrir fait connaître l'organisateur
politiques jettent outil bien à part la
commission jean louis et c'était
vraiment une très drôle d'entrevue parce
que j'écris si on avait eu des
rencontres confidentielles avec lui à
chaque fois une dizaine d' je sais pas
trop ce je veux donner une entrevue à la
caméra mais ils fermaient jamais
complètement la porte mais un certain
moment c'était le temps où jamais alors
on s'est rendu dans un café où il avait
ses habitudes
et puis là au moment où je l' approche
laborde il les caméras sont cachés dans
le camion
monsieur cloutier monsieur cloutier les
écouter bonjour moi je suis tout
bordeaux n'ont pas de partout mais le
fallait que je vois je ne pouvais pas en
avant d'autres sont donnés produits sous
l'animation
le scanner est un copain oui
non seulement y a pas fui mes gars
continuez de vous parler sacha grande
surprise il s'est même prêtée
gracieusement l'exercice de faire
d'autres images de lui complémentaires
pour le montage était complètement
surpris n'a été donnée quelques jours
vraiment quelques joueurs ont la 17ème à
l'extrême limite un fait mais celle qui
détient le record toutes catégories de
l'entrevue accordée in extremis ramassés
dans la nuit précédant la diffusion du
reportage c'est notre collègue maladroit
dans ce reportage sur la sphère shafia
le 29 janvier 2012
mohammad shafia et tooba yahya et leur
fils hamed ont été reconnus coupables de
meurtres prémédités
selon la preuve présentée par la
couronne
les quatre femmes étaient déjà mortes ou
inconsciente
quand la voiture a été poussée dans le
canal par la lexus de chafia pour
l'histoire la famille shafia ça a été
vraiment difficile d'avoir des entrevues
la communauté à regarde le montréal
était complètement sous le choque
j'avais honte
la famille étaient dispersés à travers
le monde et chacun avec des pressions
bien particulière pour ne pas nous
parler dès le début de leur relation et
nab envoie un courriel de mise en garde
à hamar sous le pseudonyme de miss
kabylie
méfie toi de mon frère si tu veux me
parler via la bibliothèque
mais si mon frère est là comporte toi
comme à l'étranger
je ne veux pas qu'il ait la moindre idée
que nous sommes amis du coin l'avait pas
dans le sport que sont pas au son frère
ils vont me tuer où on l'a frappée a
marre ça m'a pris presque un an et
convaincre je l'appelais régulièrement
il me disait ouvrit après le procès
peut-être plus tard mais y est
extrêmement fuyant il refusait de me
rencontrer même pour un café et après le
procès après procès finalement le procès
le verdict est tombé le 29 janvier 2012
et
y a accepté à ma grande surprise
finalement nous donner une entrevue le
30 à 8 heures alors le 30 et 8 heures
une tête est installé à radio-canada et
qu'une équipe de toronto qui étaient
venus pour faire l'entrevue en anglais
lahmar avait peur 8 à 8h30 9h on la
commence à l'appeler pas de réponse
9h30 10h11 a finalement je pense qu'il
était presque minuit qu'ailleurs
finalement répondu et l'oeil était dans
un tim hortons du nord de montréal
là j'ai dit busch poche m'aviez dit non
non non je bouge pas j'arrive et on est
arrivé là
on s'est mis à parler avec lui et le
yoga c'est pineau on s'est rendu compte
pour la première fois ils me parlaient
première fois je le voyais india quel
point la honte qu'il quiquine qui ne se
pardonne pas la mort de ses fils mais
bien fade note aux porteurs de ses
entrevues magnifique et j'allais leur
candidat qu'un taxi partie et cette nuit
le mans nous coucher par terre dans le
bureau après avoir fignoler les derniers
extraits du montage on diffuse le
lendemain et ce qui m'a fait beaucoup de
bien c'est que le lendemain de la
diffusion m'envoyer un texto pour me
dire merci
ça en fait du bien un jour être capable
de passer à autre chose et ça moi ça m'a
fait du bien parce que dans ce cas là
j'avais l'impression de peut-être allé
un peu loin pour le convaincre
une chose importante à vous dire si vous
voulez nous transmettre des informations
de façon complètement confidentielle
on a maintenant une plateforme sécurisée
sources anonymes
vous trouverez les instructions sur
notre site internet
rester là parce qu'après la pause on
vous parle de l'impact parfois
inattendus de certaines au reportage
l'enjmin ici qui était le leader des
trois utilisateurs
on va vérifier sur la pelouse de m
on poursuit cette émission spéciale en
vous parlant de l'impact de notre pop et
allez on vous a préparé un petit montage
qui va vous rappeler d'excellents
souvenirs et ses potes qui regardent
l'émission enquête de radio canada
on voit là toi core tier 1 qui sont à
chaque fois que enquêtes à des
révélations la toile d'araignée
s'aggrave zighoud l'émission enquête de
radio canada nous ont appris la semaine
dernière le reportage d'hier soir de
l'émission enquête présente des faits
que son trouble un géant vient
d'apprendre que d'une réunion dans catch
parle de radio canada et c'est un focus
énorme ce qu'est ce qu'ils vont sortir
la semaine prochaine c est donc non plus
d'une couture ya beaucoup de chaleur
quand on coupa enquête je pense que on
coupe énormément j'aimerais d'abord
remercié les journalistes enquêtent pour
le travail qu'ils ont fait et l'émission
d'hier soir
force est de constater que les
journalistes sont véritablement les
chiens de garde de notre démocratie
le directeur général de sûreté du québec
monsieur martin prud'homme et très
préoccupés par les impacts du reportage
diffusé hier sur la confiance des
communautés autochtones et de l'ensemble
de la population aura la sûreté du
québec
l'une des séries de reportages qui a eu
le plus d'impact sur le québec je pense
que c'est votre enquête sur la
construction même s'il n'ya pas eu
d'impact dès le début non ça se fait
graduellement donc il ya eu premier
reportage sur jocelyn dupuis ces fameux
comptes de dépenses par la suite
l'histoire du bateau de tony accurso
par la suite en effet un reportage le
sur le fond solidarité comme tel mais
tous ont culminé à un reportage il a
vraiment ça fait boum
c'est un reportage sur la collusion ça
s'appelait collision frontale c'était la
première fois qu'on documenté clairement
la collusion avec françois beaudry qui
était l'un des premiers témoins de
linotte revue à visage découvert donc à
partir de là vraiment l'impact à qui
beaucoup plus grand qu'au début il ya eu
un tel écho que dans les jours suivants
ça c'est très gratifiant quand on fait
du journalisme enquête les changements
qui surviennent c'est là où on a créé
l'escouade marteau au niveau du
groupement du québec et deux ans plus
tard après d'autres reportages de
plusieurs autres collègues de l'équipe
le gouvernement a déclenché la
commission charbonneau pour moi c'était
un show de qualité sur le travail que
les journalistes avaient fait au québec
dont une sur la construction
allez merci beaucoup de votre présence
ce soir merci beaucoup de votre grande
contribution à l'émission et puis à
bientôt
ça peut causer si le dossier de la
construction a eu beaucoup d'impact sur
le politique sur les entreprises c'est
le cas aussi de plusieurs autres
reportages qui ont changé les choses qui
ont conduit même à l'adoption de
nouvelles lois
c'était le cas du reportage de josée
dupuis sur les usines à chiots on va
reparler mais d'abord le reportage de
pascal turbine qui a contribué à changer
la vie d'un enfant et sa nouvelle
famille c'est un reportage est un peu
différent de ce qu'on fait d'habitude
dans l'émission enquête c'est un
reportage qu'on dirait dans le jargon de
dax est ce à dire que on ouvre une porte
sur un milieu que les gens ne
connaissent pas un milieu fermé dans le
sens les auditeurs soupçonne même pas
l'existence
c'est un centre de traitement à ce que
j'appellerais même un hôpital presque
psychologique pour des très jeunes
enfants de 3 à 6 ans est à environ et ça
c'est des jeux des enfants qui sont là
parce qu'ils en sont très perturbés
ils ont un diagnostic de troubles de
l'attachement profond
tous ces enfants là ont finalement
étaient tellement maltraitée on était
tellement négliger surtout c'est souvent
c'est de la négligence qui ne font pas
confiance aux adultes même aux adultes
qui peuvent les aimer alors ce que ça
prend ce sont des professionnels et donc
c'est professionnel en font un travail
extraordinaire ce travail est long
difficile
c'était difficile pour nous aussi
d'entrer dans la maison l'escargot il a
fallu convaincre le centre jeunesse de
la montérégie
ils ont fini par accepter en nous
mettant plusieurs conditions évidemment
on n'avait pas le droit d'identifier les
enfants ce qui est tout à fait normal
mais aussi il fallait qu'on est une
équipe technique réduite est toujours la
même pour pouvoir créer des liens on
était là donc pour des moments comme
ceux que vous allez voir à l'écran
c'est un moment très émouvant c'était le
moment où le petit dit l'une
après plus de trois ans de séjour à
l'escargot faisait sa valise pour aller
passer sa première nuit dans la famille
qui allait l'adopter et on était là
aussi pour la catastrophe qui a eu lieu
après
après deux mois d'intégration dans sa
nouvelle famille d'hélène a été
sommairement renvoyé c'est la première
fois qu'un enfant doit réintégrer
l'escargot mais ce n'est pas la première
fois que des mains est abandonné c'est
la deuxième fois plus officiellement
mais ça fait quand même trois milieux de
vie qui pensent qu'ils passent depuis
depuis quelques années à la suite de la
diffusion du reportage vient de famille
qui s'est proposé et qui est devenu
après un long processus la famille de
permanence des lunes il habite
d'ailleurs encore dans cette famille là
trois ans plus tard d'ailleurs une
quinzaine d'enfants qui depuis le début
de l'existence de l'escargot ont été
placés dans des familles d'accueil
permanentes ont réappris à faire
confiance à aimer des adultes et il ya
en tout quatre ressources comme celle de
l'escargot maintenant au québec il ya
200 quête qui ont contribué à modifier
la loi sur le bien-être animal
les enquêtes qu'on a fait et qui portait
entre autres une sur des usines à chiots
et l'autre sur le berger blanc
alors si on prend les usines à chiots
pouvoir démontrer qu'il y avait des
conditions déplorables dans ses usines
il fallait pouvoir y entrer
donc je me suis fait passer pour une
éleveuse j'avais l'intention d'acheter
des chiens aux producteurs des chaînes
reproductrices
alors je sais comme ça que je suis
arrivé à l'usiné mon nombreuses usines
qu'on a visités et évidemment j'avais
une caméra cachée ce qui m'a permis de
capter toutes les images en intérieur et
de pouvoir démontrer que si les
conditions étaient déplorables
alors ça ça a contribué à une communauté
de choc après ça beaucoup de gens ont
signé des pétitions il ya eu un comité
qui a été mis sur pied pour revoir la
loi sur le bien être animal alors son
reportage sur 18 nations a vraiment
contribué à ça il ya aussi le berger
blanc la fourrière le berger blanc qui
était la plus grosse fourrière au canada
on engage un collaborateur qui est allé
travailler au berger blanc pendant à peu
près un mois
lui aussi était muni d'une caméra cachée
donc ce que fait c'est que pub tournée
toutes sortes de choses tu sortes de
méthodes de façon de faire absolument
épouvantable dont ce qui se passe en
salle de tunisie quand on à diffuser ce
reportage là est vraiment sans encore
une fois ça choque est bouleversée et la
population et le gouvernement qui au
ciré décidé d'agir le berger blanc 1
était sous haute surveillance pendant
plusieurs mois puis ont dû changer leurs
méthodes comme des travaillons non il ya
eu des permis maintenant permis de garde
enregistrement des élevages plus
d'enquêteurs peines plus sévères on
parle même de peines d'emprisonnement
contre la cruauté animale et en décembre
dernier à l'unanimité l'assemblée
nationale à québec a voté pour
l'adoption de la loi 54 ce qui fait que
l'animal n'est plus considérée comme un
bien meuble mais comme un être doux et
de sensibilité alors ça c'est un pas de
géant pour protéger les animaux au
québec mais le reportage de josée dupuis
dont vous avez probablement le plus
entendu parler c'est celui ci solidaires
et se sont mises a dénoncé pour la
première fois publiquement le
comportement de certains policiers à
leur endroit
je sais pas si souvent brillé
là bas et d'ailleurs cette histoire
n'est pas finie on vous réserve d'autres
révélations qui seront divisées dans
quelques semaines très j'espère que vous
avez aimé ce retour sur les 200
premières émissions d' enquête permettez
moi de prendre un moment pour remercier
toute l'équipe qui produit avec curly
missionl enquête depuis neuf ans mais
surtout merci à vous d'être aussi fidèle
et de croire à l'importance journaliste
enquête la tradition continue on vous
revient la semaine prochaine avec une
autre enquête
merci et bon soir